it's not the root of all these
conversations it's a smoke screen
none of these conversations have
anything to do with race whatsoever
it's about protecting the american
population period
joining us now is aj louderback he's the
jackson county sheriff
we're happy to have uh you with us
sheriff lauderback
is it true um in the state of texas
that people who have been detained
because they're not here
legally their foreign nationals are
being released without coronavirus
tests it's absolutely true
absolutely true
it's even if i could continue tucker the
the uh
the memo the memo that i received
this last week um it's essentially a
defunded ice by memo by a memorandum
that was sent out by david pakoski on
january 20th
of 21. so this is a particularly
devastating document
for texans and americans here in the
united states
the message really has been sent when i
read it first
and looked at it it's a message to the
world you can come here illegally
you can commit crimes here against
americans and remain here
illegally but of all things the
coronavirus since
americans are now being told in the near
future we not may not be allowed to fly
on airplanes domestically without being
proven free of the virus without a
certificate that says we've been tested
in our negative
how in a country like that could we just
forget
to test illegal aliens for the virus
before releasing them like how did that
happen do you know
no i'm sure it wasn't a i wasn't a
forgot item
you know i don't know but in the haste
to open the border
for everyone uh in this company uh the
i mean this is uh this is uh something
that i expected to some degree
uh we went we walked this path and from
2008 to 2016.
this program that was released by
memorandum the priority enforcement
program from in 2014
2015 were where people were able to
commit crimes here against americans
the cobit issue conveniently overlooked
during this time so i you know i i
struggle for
for a thought process like many
americans and texans
on how administration can conduct
themselves in this manner
and promote a lawless attitude here
where people are going to get hurt
seriously injured
uh killed and people allowed to stay
here
which which is unbelievable yet yet
we're
yet here we sit with this uh with this
situation
yeah in a country where you're not
allowed to go to church or go to
funerals
because of chronovirus are you worried
about the
the effects of this what do you think
the effects will be
irreparable harm tucker yes we're
worried every peace officer in the
united states
should be should be extremely concerned
about the attitude the lawlessness the
complete
abject removal of law we have a
nullification of the law
here going on uh it's not we're it's not
we're gonna we're not gonna enforce
anything
we're gonna we're going to allow uh our
cbp our ice officers
uscis uh all three were affected by this
memo
which effectively guts the ina and and
handcuffs them where they're unable to
respond so
in law enforcement here those of us who
do not have the jurisdiction
to enforce the federal laws here we're
we have created a situation here
which is unthinkable for the public
the public has no idea the strength of a
memorandum
that's been filed here in the united
states by this administration
so it's uh you know i think it's our job
and i appreciate uh
you know your program and inviting me on
here to to get the word out
and spread what's happened here uh
what's happening right before our very
eyes
what this administration is doing well
we appreciate you telling us the truth
sheriff
sheriff absolutely great to see you
tonight thank you thank you